I'm sure you're raring to get to work on
the conference central application. You've already downloaded the code from
GitHub. Let's take a look at the layout of the
folders in the downloaded code. So here's where I downloaded
the code. You see there's a folder for each
lesson, lesson two, lesson three, and so on. Inside each
folder, you see folders containing the code to import into
Eclipse. You already imported this one, the Hello endpoints project.
And then next, you're going to be importing the first
of the central Conference Central projects, which is this
one here. Some folders like Lesson four include partial
code. These folders contain classes or fragments of code that
you'll be adding to your project in that lesson.
For the Conference Central application, we provide starting code
for each lesson. You can start working on it
with a starting code in the Lesson two folder and
keep working on it throughout the course. At any point if you need, you
can import the starting project for that lesson. You might want to do that for
example, if you didn't finish all the
coding exercises in the previous lesson. So now,
it's time to import the Conference Central
project from the lesson two folder into Eclipse.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And down here in the advanced section if you want,
you can enter a name for your project. Every Maven
project has an artifact which is used as its name,
but you didn't create the artifact for this project, so
feel free to add your own name if you want.
So see up here, I have my Conference Central project
and the Java code is inside the SLC folder, inside
Con > Google > Deverel > Training > Conference. And
you'll see the different packages in the
conference package. So go ahead and import the
project into Eclipse, and then answer a couple
of questions. The two files you're going to be
working with in this lesson are profile.java and
conferenceapi.java. When you've figured out what packages they're
in, come enter the values here. Where is
profile.java, and which package is conferenceapi.java are in?